- ยินดีต้อนรับสู่ทำความเข้าใจ
สารสนเทศควอนตัมและการคำนวณ
ผมชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการด้านเทคนิค
ของ IBM Quantum Education
จุดประสงค์ของซีรีส์นี้คือให้คุณ
เข้าใจสารสนเทศควอนตัมและการคำนวณอย่างแน่นหนา และนั่นหมายถึงการลงลึกในรายละเอียดทางเทคนิค
ของสารสนเทศควอนตัม และดูว่าการคำนวณ
ควอนตัมทำงานยังไงจริงๆ ทำอะไรได้และทำอะไรไม่ได้
ถ้ายังไม่ได้ดู
วิดีโอภาพรวมของซีรีส์นี้ แนะนำให้ไปดูก่อนนะ
ในวิดีโอนั้น จะมีข้อมูลว่าควรเตรียมพื้นฐาน
อะไรมาบ้างสำหรับซีรีส์นี้ รวมถึงโครงร่างของ
หัวข้อที่จะครอบคลุม
แล้วก็อย่าลืมไปดู
ตำราเรียน Qiskit ด้วยนะ ซึ่งครอบคลุมเนื้อหาเดียวกัน
กับซีรีส์วิดีโอนี้ในรูปแบบเขียน
และยังมี
ส่วนโต้ตอบและอินเทอร์เฟซกับฮาร์ดแวร์และซอฟต์แวร์ที่ออกแบบมาช่วยให้เข้าใจ
สารสนเทศควอนตัมและการคำนวณได้ดีขึ้น จะมีลิงก์ไปวิดีโอภาพรวมและตำราเรียน Qiskit
อยู่ในรายละเอียด
นี่คือบทเรียนที่หนึ่งของ
หน่วยที่หนึ่งของซีรีส์
หน่วยที่หนึ่งครอบคลุมพื้นฐาน
ของสารสนเทศควอนตัม และในบทเรียนแรกของหน่วยนี้ เราจะเน้นว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไง
สำหรับระบบเดี่ยว หมายความว่าเรามี
ระบบกายภาพหรืออุปกรณ์แค่ตัวเดียวที่
เก็บสารสนเทศควอนตัม
และเรากำลังพิจารณาว่า
ระบบหรืออุปกรณ์ตัวเดียวนั้นทำงานยังไงเมื่อแยกอยู่ตามลำพัง
ในบทเรียนถัดจากนี้ เราจะพูดถึงว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไงเมื่อมีหลายระบบ และนั่นจะทำให้เรา
อธิบายแนวคิดที่น่าสนใจ
และสำคัญได้ เช่น อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่ใช้หลาย qubit
และโปรโตคอลควอนตัม
ที่เกี่ยวข้องกับหลายบุคคลที่ประมวลผลสารสนเทศควอนตัมและส่งไป
มาระหว่างกัน
แต่ก่อนจะเข้าสู่การสนทนาเหล่านั้น มันสมเหตุสมผลที่จะเริ่มด้วย
สถานการณ์ที่ค่อนข้างเรียบง่ายของระบบเดี่ยวที่แยกอยู่ตามลำพัง
ส่วนหนึ่งเพราะเริ่มจากง่ายๆ มันดี แต่ก็เพราะว่าอย่างที่เราจะเห็น คำอธิบายว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไง
สำหรับระบบเดี่ยวที่แยกอยู่ตามลำพัง นำไปสู่คำอธิบายว่า
สำหรับหลายระบบ ได้อย่างเป็นธรรมชาติและมีเหตุผลมาก
นี่คือภาพรวมสั้นๆ ของบทเรียน
เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพูดถึง
สารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก
จุดประสงค์ของบทเรียนนี้ไม่ใช่อธิบายว่า
สารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกทำงานยังไง แต่เป็นการอธิบายว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไง
แต่ในการอธิบายว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไง มันช่วยมากถ้าเริ่ม
จากสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกและใช้มันเป็น
จุดอ้างอิงที่คุ้นเคย
เวลาพูดถึงสารสนเทศควอนตัม
ในระดับคณิตศาสตร์ สารสนเทศควอนตัมและคลาสสิกมีคำอธิบายที่คล้ายกันพอสมควร แน่นอนว่ามีความแตกต่างสำคัญบางอย่าง
จริงๆ แล้ว สารสนเทศควอนตัม
ไม่ได้แยกออกจากสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกเลย
มันเป็นส่วนขยายของ
สารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก
ความจริงก็คือ
อย่างน้อยในมุมมองของผม คุณไม่สามารถ
เข้าใจสารสนเทศควอนตัมได้จริงๆ ถ้าไม่เข้าใจ
สารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก
เพราะฉะนั้นเริ่มจากสารสนเทศ
แบบคลาสสิกก็สมเหตุสมผล
ผมคาดว่าเนื้อหานี้
จะคุ้นเคยสำหรับผู้ชมบางคน แต่แม้คุณจะคุ้นเคยแล้ว ผมไม่แนะนำให้ข้ามนะ
นอกจากจะเน้นแง่มุมของสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกที่เกี่ยวข้องที่สุดกับ
การเข้าใจสารสนเทศควอนตัมแล้ว เราจะแนะนำ
สัญกรณ์ Dirac ในส่วนนี้
ซึ่งเป็นวิธีมาตรฐาน
ที่เราจะใช้อธิบายเวกเตอร์และ
เมทริกซ์ตลอดทั้งซีรีส์
ปรากฏว่า สัญกรณ์ Dirac ไม่ได้
เฉพาะเจาะจงกับสารสนเทศควอนตัม
มันสามารถใช้ในบริบทของสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกได้เช่นกัน รวมถึงบริบทอื่นๆ อีกมากมายที่มีเวกเตอร์และเมทริกซ์เกี่ยวข้อง
จากนั้นเราจะไปสู่สารสนเทศควอนตัม โดยเฉพาะเราจะ
พูดถึงการแทนสถานะควอนตัมด้วยเวกเตอร์
การวัดแบบง่ายชนิดหนึ่งที่เรียกว่าการวัดฐานมาตรฐาน และการดำเนินการแบบยูนิทารี ซึ่งอธิบายการเปลี่ยนแปลง
ตามเวลาแบบไม่ต่อเนื่องในระบบควอนตัม
อีกครั้ง ทั้งหมดในสถานการณ์
ของระบบเดี่ยว
ก่อนเริ่มบทเรียน มันจะเป็นประโยชน์ที่จะชี้แจงว่าจริงๆ แล้วมีคำอธิบายสองแบบ
ของสารสนเทศควอนตัม คำอธิบายแบบง่าย ซึ่งเป็นสิ่งที่เรา
จะเน้นในบทเรียนนี้
และตลอดหน่วยแรกนี้ กับคำอธิบายแบบทั่วไป ซึ่งครอบคลุมในหน่วยหลังๆ โดยเฉพาะใน
หน่วยที่สามของซีรีส์
คำอธิบายแบบง่าย
ตามชื่อเลย มันง่ายกว่าและโดยปกติ
จะเรียนก่อน
ในคำอธิบายแบบง่าย อย่างที่ผมบอกไปแล้ว สถานะควอนตัมถูกแทนด้วยเวกเตอร์ และการดำเนินการถูกแทน
ด้วยเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
คำอธิบายสารสนเทศควอนตัม
แบบนี้เพียงพอสำหรับการเข้าใจ
อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมส่วนใหญ่ ตัวอย่างเช่น
มันจึงไม่ใช่ง่ายเกินไป มันเป็นของจริง
อย่างไรก็ตาม อย่างที่เราจะ
ค้นพบเรื่อยๆ มันมีข้อจำกัดบางอย่าง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราต้องการ
จำลองผลกระทบของสัญญาณรบกวนต่อระบบควอนตัม คำอธิบายนี้จะไม่เพียงพอ
คำอธิบายแบบทั่วไป
อีกด้านหนึ่ง กว้างกว่าและท้ายที่สุด
ทรงพลังกว่าในเชิงคณิตศาสตร์
ในคำอธิบายนี้ สถานะควอนตัมถูกแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ชนิดพิเศษ
ที่เรียกว่าเมทริกซ์ความหนาแน่น
และสามารถอธิบายการวัด
และการดำเนินการที่กว้างกว่าได้ รวมถึง
สัญญาณรบกวน เป็นต้น
มันสอดคล้องกับ
คำอธิบายแบบง่ายอย่างสมบูรณ์ และจริงๆ แล้ว คุณสามารถมอง
คำอธิบายแบบง่ายได้ว่า
เป็นกรณีพิเศษของ
คำอธิบายแบบทั่วไป และมันยังรวมสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกเป็นกรณีพิเศษด้วย
จริงๆ แล้วมันค่อนข้าง
สวยงามเลยในวิธีที่มันทำงาน ผมจึงแนะนำอย่างยิ่งให้เรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับคำอธิบายแบบทั่วไปนี้
เมื่อถึงเวลาที่เหมาะสม แต่คำอธิบายแบบง่ายเป็นจุดเริ่มต้นที่เป็นธรรมชาติกว่า เพราะฉะนั้นนั่นคือสิ่งที่เราจะทำ
เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพูดถึงสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก โดยเน้นไปที่แง่มุม
ของสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกที่เกี่ยวข้องที่สุด
กับสารสนเทศควอนตัม
และวิธีที่มัน
ถูกอธิบายทางคณิตศาสตร์
ลองนึกภาพว่าเรามี
ระบบกายภาพหรืออุปกรณ์บางอย่างที่เก็บข้อมูล
เราจะตั้งชื่อระบบนี้ว่า X แต่ไม่มีอะไร
สำคัญเกี่ยวกับชื่อนี้
เราจะใช้ชื่ออื่น
ก็ได้ถ้าต้องการ แต่แค่เลือกชื่อสักชื่อ
เราจะเรียกระบบนี้ว่า X
เราจะตั้งสมมติฐานเกี่ยวกับ X คือมี
เซตจำกัดของสถานะคลาสสิกที่ X สามารถอยู่ได้
ในช่วงเวลาใดก็ตาม
ตรงนี้ เมื่อผมพูดถึงสถานะคลาสสิก ผมหมายถึงการจัดเรียงของระบบที่สามารถรับรู้และ
อธิบายได้อย่างชัดเจน
โดยไม่มีความไม่แน่นอนหรือข้อผิดพลาด
จริงๆ แล้ว คุณสามารถคิดเรื่องนี้ได้โดยสัญชาตญาณ ในระดับคณิตศาสตร์ เราแค่นิยาม
เซตของสถานะคลาสสิก
เราเลือกมันตามที่ต้องการหรือในแบบที่อธิบาย
อุปกรณ์ที่เรากำลังทำงานด้วยได้ดีที่สุด
เรามาตั้งชื่อซิกม่าให้
เซตของสถานะคลาสสิกนี้ และอีกครั้ง ขอย้ำ
ว่าเราสมมติว่าซิกม่าเป็นเซตจำกัด
เซตของสถานะคลาสสิก
ของระบบ X นี้ไม่ได้ใหญ่อย่างไม่จำกัดเหมือน
เซตของจำนวนธรรมชาติทั้งหมด
มันจำกัด และนั่นก็แค่
สมมติฐานที่เราตั้งไว้
ตัวอย่างเช่น อาจเป็นว่า X เป็นบิต ซึ่งในกรณีนี้ เซตสถานะคลาสสิกก็คือเซตที่มีสอง
สมาชิก: ศูนย์และหนึ่ง
บางทีเราเรียกเซตนี้
ว่าตัวอักษรฐานสอง
อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่งคือ X เป็น
ลูกเต๋าหกด้านธรรมดา ซึ่งในกรณีนี้ สถานะคลาสสิกก็คือตัวเลขหนึ่งถึงหก
แน่นอนว่าเรากำลังพูดถึง
สิ่งที่เป็นนามธรรมตรงนี้
ลูกเต๋าหกด้านจริงอาจ
มีคุณสมบัติต่างๆ มากมาย เช่น ตำแหน่ง
ที่แน่นอน ทิศทาง
อุณหภูมิ และอื่นๆ แต่ในแง่ของข้อมูลที่เกี่ยวข้องมากที่สุดเวลาพูดถึงลูกเต๋าหกด้าน
สถานะคลาสสิกก็คือ
ตัวเลขหนึ่งถึงหก ที่ระบุด้วยจำนวนจุดบนด้านของลูกเต๋าที่หงายขึ้น
ถ้า X เป็นสวิตช์บน
พัดลมไฟฟ้าแบบมาตรฐานที่อาจมีอยู่ในบ้านของคุณ สถานะคลาสสิกก็อาจเป็น
การตั้งค่า แรง
กลาง อ่อน และปิด
เหล่านี้เป็นแค่ตัวอย่าง เราจินตนาการระบบที่มีเซตสถานะ
คลาสสิกที่ต่างจากเหล่านี้ได้ แต่หวังว่ามันจะสื่อแนวคิดได้
ว่าแนวคิดของสถานะคลาสสิกเป็นสิ่งที่ควร
คุ้นเคยและเข้าใจได้ในแง่ที่ง่ายและเป็นสัญชาตญาณ
ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ เซตของสถานะคลาสสิก
ก็แค่เซตจำกัด และแน่นอน เซตนี้ต้อง
ไม่ว่างด้วย
ต้องมีอย่างน้อย
สถานะคลาสสิกหนึ่งสถานะที่ระบบสามารถอยู่ได้ และต้องมีอย่างน้อย
สองสถานะคลาสสิก
ถ้าระบบจะมีประโยชน์ในการเก็บข้อมูล
ในบางสถานการณ์ เราอาจรู้ว่า X อยู่
ในสถานะใดสถานะหนึ่ง แต่ในหลายสถานการณ์
ที่เกิดขึ้นในบริบท
ของการประมวลผลข้อมูล อาจมีความไม่แน่นอนเกี่ยวกับสถานะคลาสสิกของ
ระบบในช่วงเวลาหนึ่ง
ทำให้สถานะคลาสสิกแต่ละสถานะที่เป็นไปได้มีความน่าจะเป็นที่เกี่ยวข้อง
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้า X เป็นบิต อาจเป็นว่า X อยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิกศูนย์
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสามในสี่ และอยู่ในสถานะหนึ่ง
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่งในสี่
เราจะเรียกสิ่งนี้
ว่าสถานะความน่าจะเป็น และเราสามารถแสดง
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นนี้ อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
เพียงแค่ระบุว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับสถานะคลาสสิกต่างๆ เป็นเท่าไหร่
วิธีที่กระชับกว่าในการแสดง
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นนี้คือด้วยเวกเตอร์ โดยเฉพาะการแทน
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
เป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ และเวกเตอร์นี้บอก
ว่าความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับสถานะคลาสสิกที่เป็นไปได้สองสถานะเป็นเท่าไหร่
ให้เฉพาะเจาะจงขึ้น รายการแรกบอก
ว่าความน่าจะเป็นที่ X จะอยู่ในสถานะศูนย์เป็นเท่าไหร่ และรายการที่สองบอก
เราว่าความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ระบบจะอยู่ในสถานะหนึ่งเป็นเท่าไหร่ นี่เป็นวิธีธรรมชาติในการเรียงลำดับตัวอักษรฐานสอง
หรืออย่างน้อย เป็นวิธีที่
เราถูกฝึกมาให้ทำ ศูนย์ก่อนและหนึ่งทีหลัง
ต่อจากนี้ เราจะใช้
คำว่าเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นเพื่อหมายถึงเวกเตอร์แบบนี้
โดยเฉพาะ มันเป็นเวกเตอร์ที่รายการทุกตัวเป็น
จำนวนจริงที่ไม่เป็นลบ และผลรวมของ
รายการทั้งหมดเท่ากับหนึ่ง
มันจึงสมเหตุสมผลที่จะ
คิดว่ารายการเหล่านี้เป็นความน่าจะเป็น
ในตัวอย่างนี้ มีแค่สองรายการเพราะมีแค่สอง
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบที่เรากำลังพูดถึง
แต่โดยทั่วไปอาจ
มีรายการจำนวนเท่าไหร่ก็ได้ โดยเข้าใจ
ว่ามีหนึ่งรายการสำหรับแต่ละสถานะคลาสสิก
ของระบบที่เรากำลังพูดถึง
เราจะยังคง
พูดเกี่ยวกับสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
และอื่นๆ ในอีกสักครู่ แต่ก่อนอื่น มันจะมีประโยชน์มาก
ที่จะแนะนำสัญกรณ์
สำหรับการอธิบายเวกเตอร์ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อสัญกรณ์ Dirac
จริงๆ แล้ว นี่เป็นแค่ส่วนแรก
ของสัญกรณ์ Dirac
มีอีกสองสามแง่มุม
ของสัญกรณ์ Dirac ที่เราจะเห็นอีก
สักหน่อยในบทเรียนนี้
สัญกรณ์นี้จะ
เป็นหัวใจสำคัญในวิธีที่เราอธิบายสารสนเทศควอนตัม จึงจำเป็นต้อง
เข้าใจว่ามันทำงานยังไง
แต่โชคดีที่มันง่ายมากและจริงๆ ไม่ได้มี
อะไรที่เกี่ยวข้องกับสารสนเทศควอนตัมโดยเฉพาะ
เราจึงแนะนำมันได้ตอนนี้
ในบริบทที่คุ้นเคยของสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก
เช่นเดิม เราสมมติว่าเรามีเซตซิกม่าของ
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบบางระบบ และสมมติว่า
เรามีการเรียงลำดับ
ของสถานะคลาสสิกเหล่านี้ เหมือนกับที่เราอ้างถึงการ
เรียงลำดับของตัวอักษรฐานสอง
ในตัวอย่างก่อนหน้า อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการพูดก็คือ
สมาชิกของซิกม่าถูกจับคู่กับ
จำนวนเต็ม
ตั้งแต่หนึ่งถึงจำนวน
สมาชิกทั้งหมดในซิกม่า ซึ่งสัญกรณ์ตรงนี้ที่มีแถบสองแถบรอบซิกม่าหมายถึง
นั่นคือจำนวน
สมาชิกในเซตซิกม่า
ก็มีสถานะแรก
สถานะที่สอง และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ
การเรียงลำดับหรือ
การจับคู่ที่เราเลือกจริงๆ แล้วไม่ได้สำคัญมากนัก
สิ่งที่สำคัญจริงๆ คือ
เรามีการเรียงลำดับและยึดตามมัน
สำหรับเซตสถานะคลาสสิก
หลายอันที่เราจะเจอ จะมีการเรียงลำดับมาตรฐานเหมือนกับที่เรามีกับ
ตัวอักษรฐานสอง
และถ้าไม่มีการเรียงลำดับมาตรฐาน เราก็แค่เลือกขึ้นมาเอง
แต่ไม่ว่าจะเป็นอะไร เราก็เข้าใจตรงกันว่าจะยึดตามมัน
ทีนี้ สัญกรณ์ที่
กำลังจะแนะนำเป็นแบบนี้
สำหรับสถานะคลาสสิก a ใดๆ
จากเซตซิกม่าของเรา เราเขียนแบบนี้ ซึ่งอ่านว่า ket a
หมายถึงเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
ที่มีหนึ่งในรายการที่ตรงกับ a และศูนย์สำหรับรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมด
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรากลับ
ไปที่ตัวอักษรฐานสอง ซึ่งอย่างที่คุณอาจเดาได้ เป็นตัวอย่างที่สำคัญมาก
ที่เราจะกลับมาอีกซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่า ket ศูนย์ และ ket หนึ่ง คือเวกเตอร์ที่นิยามไว้ตรงนี้
ket ศูนย์ คือเวกเตอร์
ที่มีหนึ่งในรายการที่ตรงกับสถานะคลาสสิกศูนย์ ซึ่งเป็นรายการแรก
และศูนย์สำหรับรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมด และในกรณีนี้ มีแค่
รายการอื่นอีกหนึ่งรายการ
ในทำนองเดียวกัน ket หนึ่ง คือ
เวกเตอร์ตรงนี้ ที่มีหนึ่งใน
รายการที่ตรงกับหนึ่ง
ซึ่งเป็นรายการที่สอง และศูนย์สำหรับรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมด ซึ่งก็แค่รายการเดียว
นี่อีกตัวอย่างหนึ่ง ในตัวอย่างนี้ เรามี
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกซิกม่าที่ตรงกับชุดไพ่สี่ชุด
ในสำรับไพ่มาตรฐาน: คลับ เพชร โพดำ และโพแดง
ในกรณีนี้ จริงๆ ไม่มีการเรียงลำดับ
ที่ทุกคนเห็นตรงกันของชุดไพ่เหล่านี้
สำหรับเกมไพ่หลายเกม ไม่มีการเรียงลำดับเลย แค่มีสี่ชุดที่ต่างกันแค่นั้น และมีเกมไพ่ต่างๆ ที่เรียงลำดับชุดไพ่เหล่านี้
แตกต่างกันไป แต่จริงๆ มันไม่สำคัญ
เราแค่เลือก
การเรียงลำดับแบบที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ก็ได้
บังเอิญเป็นการเรียงตามตัวอักษรภาษาอังกฤษของชื่อชุดไพ่ทั้งสี่ที่เขียนเป็นภาษาอังกฤษ
สมมติว่าเราเลือก
การเรียงลำดับนี้ เราก็นิยามเวกเตอร์สี่ตัว: ket คลับ, ket เพชร,
ket โพดำ, และ ket โพแดง
อย่างที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ และเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้ตรงกับ
คำอธิบายทั่วไปที่คุณเห็นข้างบน
เมื่อเราได้เลือก
การเรียงลำดับนี้สำหรับชุดไพ่ทั้งสี่แล้ว
เราสามารถทำแบบเดียวกันสำหรับเซตสถานะ
คลาสสิกใดๆ ที่เราเลือก
โปรดจำไว้ว่าเซตสถานะ
คลาสสิกหมายถึงเซตจำกัดและไม่ว่างเสมอ
เวกเตอร์ในรูปแบบนี้
เรียกว่าเวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน และเป็นข้อเท็จจริงพื้นฐานมากของเวกเตอร์ว่าทุกเวกเตอร์สามารถ
แสดงในแบบที่เป็นเอกลักษณ์
เป็นผลรวมเชิงเส้น
ของเวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน
ตัวอย่างเช่น กลับไปที่ตัวอย่างเมื่อสักครู่ เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
ที่เราเห็นสามารถแสดง
อย่างที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ มันเป็นแค่วิธีทางเลือกในการแสดงเวกเตอร์
ที่จะเป็นประโยชน์มากด้วยเหตุผลหลายประการต่อจากนี้
และด้วยสัญกรณ์นั้นอยู่ในมือแล้ว มากลับไปที่การสนทนา
เรื่องสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกและสถานะความน่าจะเป็นกัน
มาพิจารณาดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
เมื่อเราวัดระบบขณะที่มันอยู่ในสถานะความน่าจะเป็นบางอย่าง
โดยปกติเราอาจ
ไม่เรียกว่าการวัดหรือการกระทำของการวัด
บางอย่างในบริบทคลาสสิก แต่คำนี้ก็สมเหตุสมผล
โดยพื้นฐานแล้ว เมื่อเราพูด
ถึงการวัดระบบ X ในบริบทนี้ เราแค่หมายความว่าเรามองมันและจดจำว่ามันอยู่ในสถานะอะไร
แน่นอนว่าเมื่อเรามองที่ระบบ เราไม่เห็นสถานะความน่าจะเป็น เราเห็นสถานะคลาสสิก
และสถานะคลาสสิก
ที่เราเห็นเป็นสถานะที่เราจะ
จินตนาการว่าถูกเลือกแบบสุ่มตามความน่าจะเป็น
คุณอาจคัดค้านใน
เชิงปรัชญาว่าสถานะคลาสสิกที่เราเห็นถูกเลือกแบบสุ่มอย่างใด
ในขณะที่เราวัดหรือมองระบบ ระบบก็แค่อยู่ในสถานะ
คลาสสิกบางอย่างมาตลอด
และเราก็แค่บังเอิญ
รู้ว่าสถานะนั้นคืออะไร แต่เพื่อการคิดเกี่ยวกับกรอบ
คณิตศาสตร์ที่เรากำลังใช้
ก็โอเคที่จะคิดแบบนี้ และการทำเช่นนั้นจะทำให้เราเปรียบเทียบกับ
สารสนเทศควอนตัมได้ในอีกสักพัก
สมมติว่าสถานะ
คลาสสิกที่เราเห็นคือสถานะคลาสสิก a ซึ่งอาจเป็นสถานะใดๆ ในเซตซิกม่าของเรา
สิ่งนี้เปลี่ยนสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นของ X โดยทั่วไป อย่างน้อยจากมุมมองของเรา
ความน่าจะเป็นไม่มี
ความสำคัญอีกต่อไปเพราะตอนนี้เรารู้แล้วว่า
สถานะคลาสสิกของ X คืออะไร
มันคือ a และไม่มีความ
ไม่แน่นอนเกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้อีกแล้ว
ตอนนี้เราจึงพูดได้ว่า
ความน่าจะเป็นที่ระบบอยู่ในสถานะ a เท่ากับหนึ่ง
เรารู้เพราะเราเพิ่งมองมันและเห็นว่าสถานะคลาสสิกคือ a สถานะความน่าจะเป็นใหม่ของ X คือสถานะที่
ความน่าจะเป็นของ
การอยู่ในสถานะคลาสสิก a เท่ากับหนึ่ง
และสถานะความน่าจะเป็นนั้นถูกแทนด้วย
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น ket a
เรามีหนึ่งในรายการที่ตรงกับสถานะคลาสสิก a และศูนย์ในรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมด
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเรา
พิจารณาสถานการณ์ที่ X เป็นบิตอีกครั้ง และมี
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นเดิม
ถ้าเราวัด X เราจินตนาการได้ว่ามี
การเปลี่ยนแปลงเกิดขึ้น
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสามในสี่ เราเห็นสถานะคลาสสิกศูนย์ และโดยการวัด เราเปลี่ยนไปเป็น ket ศูนย์
เป็นสถานะความน่าจะเป็นของเรา
และด้วยความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่งในสี่ เราเปลี่ยนไปเป็น ket หนึ่ง
คุณอาจคิดว่าเรื่องนี้เป็นการเปลี่ยนแปลงของความรู้ ถ้าต้องการ แทนที่จะเป็นการเปลี่ยนแปลง
ทางกายภาพจริงๆ
แต่สิ่งสำคัญสำหรับ
บทเรียนนี้คือจดจำว่าคณิตศาสตร์ทำงานยังไง
มันค่อนข้างเล็กน้อยจริงๆ แต่โดยการจดจำความเล็กน้อยนี้ คำอธิบายที่คล้ายกัน
สำหรับบริบทควอนตัม
อาจดูลึกลับน้อยลงหน่อย
หมายเหตุสุดท้ายคือสำหรับคนอื่นที่ไม่ได้เห็นว่า
สถานะคลาสสิกของ X คืออะไรเมื่อเราวัด
สถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ก็จะไม่เปลี่ยนตามธรรมชาติจากการที่เราวัด
ไม่เป็นไร คนต่างกันสามารถ
มีความรู้ต่างกันเกี่ยวกับระบบหนึ่งๆ และเลือก
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่ต่างกันตามนั้น
เพื่อแทนความรู้ของพวกเขา
เกี่ยวกับระบบนั้น
ในส่วนสุดท้ายของการสนทนาเรื่องสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก เราจะพูดถึงการดำเนินการแบบคลาสสิกที่สามารถทำกับระบบได้
เริ่มด้วยการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้
เมื่อเราทำการดำเนินการกับระบบ สถานะของมันก็จะเปลี่ยนตามผลลัพธ์ และในบริบทนี้ คำว่ากำหนดได้หมายความว่า
ผลของการทำ
การดำเนินการขึ้นอยู่กับสถานะคลาสสิก
ที่ระบบอยู่ทั้งหมด
ก่อนที่จะทำการดำเนินการ
พูดอีกอย่างก็คือ
ไม่มีองค์ประกอบของโอกาสเมื่อทำ
การดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้ จึงไม่มีความสุ่ม
หรือความไม่แน่นอนเข้ามาเกี่ยวข้อง
ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ การดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้
ถูกอธิบายด้วยฟังก์ชัน
ทุกฟังก์ชัน f ในรูปแบบ
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ ซึ่งหมายความว่าทั้งอินพุตและเอาต์พุตของฟังก์ชัน
ตรงกับสมาชิกของ
เซตสถานะคลาสสิกซิกม่า อธิบายการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้
สถานะคลาสสิก a ถูก
แปลงเป็นสถานะ f ของ a สำหรับแต่ละตัวเลือกของสถานะ a
สำหรับทุกฟังก์ชัน f ในรูปแบบนี้ จะมีเมทริกซ์ M เอกลักษณ์เดียวเสมอที่สอดคล้องกับเงื่อนไข
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
นั่นคือการคูณ
M กับเวกเตอร์ ket a ได้เวกเตอร์ ket f ของ a
และนั่นเป็นจริงสำหรับ
ทุกตัวเลือกของสถานะคลาสสิก a
ไม่ยากเกินไปที่จะเขียน
คำอธิบายชัดเจนของ M สำหรับฟังก์ชัน f ใดๆ
ในรูปแบบนี้ที่เราเลือก
มันจะมีหนึ่งตัวเดียว
พอดีหนึ่งตัวในแต่ละคอลัมน์ โดยรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมดเป็นศูนย์
และนี่คือสูตร รายการ b, a ของ M เท่ากับหนึ่ง ถ้า b เท่ากับ f ของ a
และนอกเหนือจากนั้นก็เท่ากับศูนย์ และหมายถึง
รายการของ M ที่แถวตรงกับ b
และคอลัมน์ตรงกับ a
เราจะเห็นตัวอย่างสักสองสามตัวอย่างในอีกสักครู่ และเราจะเห็นว่าสูตรนี้ใช้ได้ยังไง
ตอนนี้อาจยังไม่ชัดเจนว่าทำไมเราถึงอยากเอาฟังก์ชันมาแสดงเป็นเมทริกซ์แบบนี้
แต่มันสมเหตุสมผลที่จะทำเช่นนี้ เหตุผลหนึ่ง และอาจเป็นเหตุผลหลัก คือถ้าเรามีระบบ
อยู่ในสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
และเราทำการดำเนินการแบบ
กำหนดได้กับระบบนั้น สถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ที่ได้จะได้มา
จากการคูณเมทริกซ์กับเวกเตอร์ คือถ้าระบบอยู่
ในสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ที่แทนด้วย
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น v บางตัว และเราทำการดำเนินการ
แบบกำหนดได้ที่อธิบายด้วย M
กับระบบนั้น สถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่ได้จะเป็น M คูณ v
ตรงนี้ ลูกศรที่มี
ขีดเล็กๆ ตรงนี้เป็นแค่สัญกรณ์ทั่วไปในคณิตศาสตร์เพื่อบอกว่าสิ่งหนึ่ง
ถูกแปลงไปเป็น
อีกสิ่งหนึ่ง คุณจะใช้ลูกศรธรรมดาก็ได้ แต่แบบนี้เป็นธรรมเนียม
และจดจำได้ง่าย และอาจเจาะจงกว่าลูกศรธรรมดาที่อาจมีหลายความหมาย
ทีนี้มาดูตัวอย่างหรือกลุ่มของตัวอย่างกัน
มาพิจารณาว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเราใช้เซตสถานะคลาสสิกซิกม่าเป็นตัวอักษรฐานสองอีกครั้ง
ไม่มีฟังก์ชันในรูปแบบที่เราพูดถึงมากนักเมื่อนี่เป็นเซตสถานะคลาสสิกของเรา และให้เจาะจงขึ้น มีแค่สี่
ฟังก์ชันในรูปแบบนี้
ตรงนี้ ฟังก์ชันทั้งสี่ถูกอธิบายด้วยตารางค่าที่เรียกว่า
ตารางแรกอธิบาย
ฟังก์ชันแรก ที่เราตั้งชื่อว่า f1
สำหรับแต่ละอินพุตที่เป็นไปได้ทางซ้าย เราระบุ
เอาต์พุตที่ตรงกันทางขวา f1 ของศูนย์เท่ากับศูนย์
และ f1 ของหนึ่งก็เท่ากับศูนย์เช่นกัน นั่นคือ f1 เป็น
ฟังก์ชันคงที่ศูนย์
มันให้ค่าศูนย์เสมอ
ฟังก์ชันที่สอง f2
เป็นฟังก์ชันเอกลักษณ์
เอาต์พุตเท่ากับอินพุตเสมอ อย่างที่เห็นจากตารางที่สอง
ฟังก์ชันที่สาม f3
อธิบายด้วยตารางที่สาม
f3 ของศูนย์เท่ากับหนึ่ง และ f3 ของหนึ่งเท่ากับศูนย์
ฟังก์ชันนี้รู้จักกันดีกว่า
ในชื่อฟังก์ชัน NOT หรือการปฏิเสธเชิงตรรกะ
บางทีเราก็เรียกมันว่าบิตฟลิปเพราะมันพลิกศูนย์
เป็นหนึ่งและหนึ่งเป็นศูนย์
ฟังก์ชันสุดท้าย f4
ก็เป็นฟังก์ชันคงที่เหมือนฟังก์ชันแรก แต่ตัวนี้เป็นฟังก์ชันคงที่หนึ่ง
เพราะมันให้ค่าหนึ่งเสมอ
และนั่นคือฟังก์ชันทั้งสี่ตัวเท่านั้นจากตัวอักษรฐานสองไปยังตัวมันเอง
นี่คือเมทริกซ์สี่ตัวที่ตรงกับฟังก์ชันทั้งสี่ที่อธิบาย
ด้วยสูตรจากก่อนหน้านี้
ซึ่งคุณเห็นตรงนี้ และถ้าอยากตรวจสอบ คุณสามารถหยุดวิดีโอแล้วเช็คได้
แค่จำไว้ว่าสำหรับเมทริกซ์ ลำดับของดัชนีคือแถวก่อน คอลัมน์ทีหลังเสมอ
รายการ b, a ตรงกับ
แถว b และคอลัมน์ a หรือแถวที่ตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิก b
และคอลัมน์ที่ตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิก a
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าเราดู
ฟังก์ชันแรก f1 ของศูนย์เท่ากับศูนย์
และตามนั้น รายการ
ศูนย์, ศูนย์ ของ M1 เท่ากับหนึ่ง
ส่วนรายการ หนึ่ง, ศูนย์
ตรงนี้เท่ากับศูนย์ และคุณสามารถทำแบบเดียวกันสำหรับกรณี
ที่อินพุตเท่ากับหนึ่ง และเช่นกันสำหรับ
ฟังก์ชันอีกสามตัว
คุณยังสามารถตรวจสอบว่า
สูตรจากก่อนหน้านี้เป็นจริง โดยไล่ทีละตัว
ผ่านความเป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดเพื่อยืนยัน
และจริงๆ แล้ว ถ้าคุณคิดเกี่ยวกับวิธีที่
การคูณเมทริกซ์ทำงาน คุณแค่ดูก็เห็นได้เลย
เมื่อคุณคูณเมทริกซ์กับเวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐานแบบนี้ คุณจินตนาการได้ว่า
คุณเอาอินพุต
หย่อนลงไปทาง
ด้านบนของเมทริกซ์ในคอลัมน์ที่ตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิก
ที่อยู่ข้างใน ket และเอาต์พุตที่คุณ
ได้ก็เป็นแค่คอลัมน์นั้นในรูปเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
ตัวอย่างเช่น M3 คูณกับ ket
ศูนย์ ให้ผลเป็น ศูนย์, หนึ่ง
ในรูปเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น ซึ่งก็คือ ket หนึ่ง
M3 คูณกับ ket
หนึ่ง ให้ผลเป็น หนึ่ง, ศูนย์ ซึ่งก็คือ ket ศูนย์ และอื่นๆ
เราจะพูดถึงการดำเนินการบน
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นเพิ่มเติมในอีกสักครู่ แต่ก่อนอื่น มาแนะนำส่วนที่สองของสัญกรณ์ Dirac กัน
นี่จะช่วย
ในการพูดถึงการดำเนินการและคิดเกี่ยวกับมันในรูปเมทริกซ์ และจะเป็นเครื่องมือมาตรฐาน
ที่เราจะใช้ต่อไป การเตรียมการก็เหมือนเดิม
เรามีเซตสถานะคลาสสิกซิกม่าที่เราใช้งาน และเราสมมติว่ามีวิธี
เรียงลำดับสถานะคลาสสิกเหล่านั้น
จากนั้นเราเขียนสิ่ง
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้ ซึ่งคราวนี้
แถบเฉียงอยู่ทางซ้ายแทนที่จะอยู่ทางขวา หมายถึง
เวกเตอร์แถวที่มีหนึ่ง
ในรายการที่
ตรงกับ a และศูนย์สำหรับรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมดที่ตรงกับสถานะ
คลาสสิกอื่นๆ
ความแตกต่างระหว่าง
สิ่งนี้กับ ket a ก็คือนี่เป็นเวกเตอร์แถว และ
ket a เป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
แต่นอกเหนือจากนั้น เวกเตอร์
ถูกนิยามในแบบที่คล้ายกัน
เราอ่านสิ่งนี้ว่า bra a ไม่แน่ใจว่ามันตลก
หรือเปล่า แต่แนวคิดก็คือชื่อ bra และ ket
เป็นสองซีกของคำว่า bracket และเราจะพูดเพิ่มเติม
เกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้ในอีกสักครู่
แต่ก่อนอื่น มาดู
ตัวอย่างสั้นๆ กัน
สำหรับตัวอักษรฐานสอง เรามี bra ศูนย์ คือ
เวกเตอร์แถวตรงนี้ ซึ่งคล้ายกับ ket a
ยกเว้นว่าเป็นเวกเตอร์แถว
แทนที่จะเป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ และ bra หนึ่ง คือเวกเตอร์ตรงนี้
โดยทั่วไป ถ้าเราคูณเวกเตอร์แถว
กับเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ โดยคิดว่าเป็นเมทริกซ์
ที่มีแค่
แถวเดียวหรือคอลัมน์เดียว เราจะได้เมทริกซ์หนึ่งคูณหนึ่ง ซึ่งเราคิดว่า
เป็นสเกลาร์ได้
ตรงนี้ คุณควร
คิดว่าดาวเหล่านี้แทนจำนวนใดๆ
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรา
คูณเวกเตอร์แถว bra a กับเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ ket b
ก็มีสองสิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นได้
อย่างแรกคือ a กับ b เท่ากัน คือเป็นสถานะคลาสสิกเดียวกัน ซึ่งในกรณีนี้ หนึ่งจะตรงกัน
และผลคูณจะเท่ากับหนึ่ง หรืออาจเป็นกรณีที่
a กับ b ต่างกัน
หนึ่งจึงไม่ตรงกันและผลคูณเท่ากับศูนย์
วิธีง่ายๆ ในการแสดง
ข้อสังเกตเหล่านี้เป็นแบบตรงนี้
และเพื่อความเรียบร้อย เราเขียนผลคูณนี้แบบนี้ โดยมีแค่แถบเดียวตรงกลาง และมันหมายความเหมือนกัน
กับตรงนี้ทุกประการ
และตอนนี้คุณเห็นแล้วว่า
bra กับ ket ไปด้วยกันเป็น bracket ซึ่ง
เรียกอีกอย่างว่าผลคูณภายใน
และนั่นเป็นสิ่ง
ที่สำคัญมากที่เราจะกลับมาพูดถึง
ในบทเรียนที่สาม
การคูณเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
กับเวกเตอร์แถว อีกด้านหนึ่ง จะให้เมทริกซ์อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
ตัวอย่างเช่น กลับไปที่
ตัวอักษรฐานสองอีกครั้ง ถ้าเราคูณ ket ศูนย์ กับ bra ศูนย์
สิ่งที่ได้คือเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ และเราไล่ดู
ความเป็นไปได้อื่นๆ ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
ket ศูนย์ คูณ bra หนึ่ง ให้
เมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ ที่หนึ่งย้ายมา
อยู่ตำแหน่งนี้
ket หนึ่ง bra ศูนย์ หน้าตาแบบนี้ และนี่คือ ket หนึ่ง bra หนึ่ง
สิ่งที่เราเห็นคือมีหนึ่งตัวเดียวในเมทริกซ์ที่นอกนั้นเป็นศูนย์ทั้งหมด และตำแหน่งของหนึ่งนั้น
ถูกกำหนดโดย
สถานะคลาสสิกที่เราเลือกใน bra และ ket
ให้เจาะจงขึ้น และ
นี่เป็นจริงโดยทั่วไป สำหรับเซตสถานะคลาสสิกใดๆ เมทริกซ์ที่เราได้จาก
การคูณ ket a กับ bra b
คือเมทริกซ์ที่มีหนึ่งในรายการ a, b และศูนย์สำหรับรายการอื่นๆ ทั้งหมด
และเมื่อเรามีทั้ง
ส่วนแรกและส่วนที่สองของสัญกรณ์ Dirac แล้ว เรามีเครื่องมือที่สะดวกมากสำหรับเชื่อมโยงการดำเนินการกับเมทริกซ์
มากลับไปที่
การดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้สักครู่ และจำไว้ว่าก่อนหน้านี้
ในบทเรียน
ได้กล่าวว่าสำหรับทุกฟังก์ชัน f ใน
รูปแบบตรงนี้ เรามีการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้ที่แปลง a เป็น f ของ a
สำหรับทุกสถานะคลาสสิก a ที่เป็นไปได้ และเราบอกว่าสำหรับ
ฟังก์ชันแบบนี้ จะมีเมทริกซ์ M เอกลักษณ์เดียว
ที่ทำงานแบบนี้เสมอ
กับสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
โดยใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac เราสามารถแสดงเมทริกซ์นี้ได้ง่ายๆ อย่างที่เห็นตรงนี้
และเราเห็นว่าบางครั้ง
สามารถทำงานกับเมทริกซ์ทั้งหมด
ภายในกรอบของสัญกรณ์ Dirac ได้
โดยไม่ต้องแปลง
เป็นเวกเตอร์และเมทริกซ์จริงๆ คือสี่เหลี่ยมที่เต็มไปด้วยตัวเลข
ในกรณีนี้ เราตรวจสอบได้ว่า
สูตรที่ต้องการเป็นจริง โดยคูณ M กับ ket a
เราแทนค่า
นิพจน์ของ M แบบนี้ และเราเอาวงเล็บออกแล้วเชื่อม bra
b กับ ket a แบบนี้
และนั่นเป็นเพราะ
การคูณเมทริกซ์เป็นเชิงเส้น ในกรณีนี้ในอาร์กิวเมนต์แรก และเป็นสมาคม จึงเอาวงเล็บออกได้
และตอนนี้ จำไว้ว่าเรามี a คงที่ตัวหนึ่งที่เรากำลังพูดถึง เมื่อเราบวกรวมทุก
ตัวเลือกของ b ที่เป็นไปได้
bracket ตรงนี้จะ
เท่ากับศูนย์เสมอเมื่อ b ไม่เท่ากับ a จึงไม่มี
ส่วนร่วมในผลรวม
และเมื่อ b เท่ากับ a bracket จะเท่ากับหนึ่ง เราจึงเหลือ
แค่พจน์เดียวตรงนี้
นั่นคือสูตรที่เราต้องการ เราจึงมีวิธีที่ดีและง่ายในการแสดงฟังก์ชันเป็นเมทริกซ์
นอกจากการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้ เรายังมีการดำเนินการที่
ตัวมันเองสร้างความสุ่มหรือความไม่แน่นอนเกี่ยวกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบ
เราใช้คำว่าการดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับการดำเนินการแบบนี้ และให้เจาะจง เมื่อพูดว่าการดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็น
เราหมายถึงการดำเนินการที่
อาจสร้างความสุ่ม การดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้จึงเป็นกรณีพิเศษ
ของการดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็น
ที่บังเอิญไม่ได้
สร้างความสุ่มใดๆ
นี่คือตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ที่
มีความสุ่มเกิดขึ้น
นี่เป็นการดำเนินการกับบิตเดียว วิธีที่มันทำงานคือถ้าสถานะคลาสสิก
ของบิตเป็นศูนย์
ก็ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้น บิตยังเป็นศูนย์อยู่ แต่ถ้าสถานะ
คลาสสิกของบิตเป็นหนึ่ง การดำเนินการจะพลิกบิตเป็นศูนย์
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับ 1/2
ไม่มีชื่อเฉพาะ
สำหรับการดำเนินการนี้ อย่างน้อยเท่าที่ผมรู้
มันเป็นแค่ตัวอย่าง แต่คุณจินตนาการได้ว่าทำ
การดำเนินการนี้กับบิต
เหมือนกับการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้ การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นก็สามารถ
แทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ได้ และผลกระทบต่อสถานะความน่าจะเป็น
ก็ได้จากการคูณเมทริกซ์กับเวกเตอร์เหมือนเดิม
คราวนี้ ไม่จำเป็นว่าเมทริกซ์จะมีหนึ่งพอดีหนึ่งตัวในแต่ละคอลัมน์และศูนย์อื่นๆ
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็น
แทนได้ทั่วไปด้วยเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก
เหล่านี้คือเมทริกซ์ที่รายการทุกตัวเป็น
จำนวนจริงที่ไม่เป็นลบ และรายการใน
แต่ละคอลัมน์รวมกันเท่ากับหนึ่ง
เทียบเท่ากับการบอกว่า
เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกคือเมทริกซ์ที่ทุกคอลัมน์
เป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
มันสมเหตุสมผลเมื่อคิดเกี่ยวกับ
ผลกระทบของเมทริกซ์ต่อเวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน
คุณพิจารณาสถานะ
คลาสสิกที่ต้องการและจินตนาการว่าหย่อนสถานะนั้นลงไปด้านบนของเมทริกซ์ในคอลัมน์ที่ตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกนั้น
และคอลัมน์นั้นบอกว่า
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่ออกมาเป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นคืออะไร
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็น
ในตัวอย่างของเรา เป็นต้น ถูกอธิบายด้วยเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้
ถ้าเราทำการดำเนินการนี้
กับสถานะคลาสสิกศูนย์ สถานะความน่าจะเป็นที่ได้ก็คือคอลัมน์แรก
ซึ่งก็คือสถานะคลาสสิกศูนย์อีกครั้ง หรือเทียบเท่าคือสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นที่ศูนย์เกิดขึ้นด้วยความน่าจะเป็นหนึ่ง
ถ้าแทนที่ เราทำการดำเนินการนี้กับสถานะคลาสสิกหนึ่ง เราก็แค่สุ่มบิตอย่างมีผล และตามนั้นเราได้
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นตรงนี้
ที่ความน่าจะเป็นสำหรับ
แต่ละสถานะที่เป็นไปได้เท่ากับ 1/2
โดยทั่วไป ถ้าเราทำการดำเนินการนี้กับสถานะความน่าจะเป็นใดๆ ผลก็เป็นแค่
ค่าเฉลี่ยถ่วงน้ำหนักระหว่างสองคอลัมน์
เพราะนั่นคือวิธีที่การคูณ
เมทริกซ์กับเวกเตอร์ทำงาน
มันเป็นเชิงเส้น เราจึงแค่เฉลี่ยผลลัพธ์สอง
แบบที่เป็นไปได้ตามนั้น
เมื่อเราคิดเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการ
แบบความน่าจะเป็นแบบนี้ เป็นเรื่องธรรมชาติที่จะคิดว่า
มันอาจสร้างหรือฉีดความสุ่มเข้ามา
เราแค่อ่านคอลัมน์ทีละคอลัมน์และเราเห็นความสุ่ม
ที่มันสร้างสำหรับแต่ละสถานะคลาสสิกที่เป็นไปได้
คุณยังสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นในมุมที่ต่างออกไปเล็กน้อย คือมันเป็นการเลือกแบบสุ่มของการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น ในตัวอย่างของเรา เราคิดได้ว่าการดำเนินการนี้เทียบเท่ากับ
การโยนเหรียญที่ยุติธรรม
แล้วทำฟังก์ชันคงที่ศูนย์
หรือฟังก์ชันเอกลักษณ์
แต่ละอย่างด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 1/2
และคุณเห็นสิ่งนั้นสะท้อน
อยู่ตรงนี้ในสมการนี้
เป็นไปได้เสมอสำหรับ
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นใดๆ และเข้าใจได้ง่าย
ถ้าคุณเลือกแบบสุ่ม
เป็นส่วนหนึ่งของกระบวนการ คุณจินตนาการได้เสมอว่าเลือกแบบสุ่มล่วงหน้า
แล้วฝังตัวเลือกเหล่านั้น
ลงในชุดของการดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้
บางครั้งมันช่วยมากที่จะคิดเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการ
แบบความน่าจะเป็นแบบนี้ และเราจะเห็นตัวอย่าง
ของเรื่องนี้ในอีกสองสามบทเรียน
สิ่งสุดท้ายที่จะพูด
เกี่ยวกับสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกในบทเรียนนี้เกี่ยวกับการประกอบ
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็น ซึ่งก็แค่หมายถึงทำ
อันหนึ่งตามอีกอัน
สมมติว่าเรา
มีระบบชื่อ X และ M1 ถึง Mn เป็นเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกที่แทน
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นกับ X
ลองจินตนาการว่าเรามี
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น v ซึ่งแทนสถานะ
ความน่าจะเป็นของ X ในช่วงเวลาหนึ่ง แล้วเราใช้
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นแรกกับ X ซึ่งแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ M1 แล้วใช้การดำเนินการ
แบบความน่าจะเป็นที่สอง
ซึ่งแทนด้วย M2
ถ้าเราทำเช่นนั้น
เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นที่ได้หลังใช้แค่การดำเนินการ
แรกคือ M1 คูณ v
แล้วเมื่อเราใช้
การดำเนินการที่สอง เวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นที่ได้คือ M2 คูณกับเวกเตอร์ที่ได้
หลังใช้ M1 หน้าตาก็เป็นแบบนี้
การคูณเมทริกซ์
เป็นการดำเนินการแบบสมาคม หมายความว่าไม่สำคัญว่าเราวางวงเล็บตรงไหน
เราจึงวางวงเล็บ
แบบนี้ก็ได้เช่นกัน
มันง่ายมาก แต่ก็น่าสนใจเพราะมันเผยว่าเรา
คิดเกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการที่ใช้ M1 ก่อน
แล้วใช้ M2
เป็นการดำเนินการเดียวได้
พูดอีกอย่างก็คือ
การดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นที่ได้จากการประกอบ
การดำเนินการแรกและที่สอง ถูกแทนด้วย
ผลคูณเมทริกซ์ M2 คูณ M1
และนั่นเป็นการดำเนินการเดียวกันไม่ว่าจะเริ่มจาก
สถานะความน่าจะเป็นอะไร
เราไม่จำเป็นต้องรู้อะไรเกี่ยวกับเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น v เพื่อคิดหรืออธิบาย
การดำเนินการที่ประกอบกันนี้
สังเกตว่าลำดับ
ตรงนี้คือ M2 อยู่ทางซ้ายและ M1 อยู่ทางขวา เพราะ
เมทริกซ์ทางขวา M1
เป็นตัวที่ถูก
คูณกับเวกเตอร์ v ส่วน M2 ถูกคูณ
กับเวกเตอร์ที่ได้หลังคูณด้วย M1
เราจึงต้องจำไว้เสมอว่าลำดับมันกลับกัน
ในบางแง่
การดำเนินการที่ทำ
ก่อนอยู่ทางขวา และการดำเนินการที่ทำหลังสุดหรือในกรณีนี้ที่สอง
อยู่ทางซ้าย
ถ้าเราไม่หยุดที่การดำเนินการที่สองแต่ใช้ทั้งหมดตาม
ลำดับเริ่มจากแรกจนถึงสุดท้ายซึ่งคือ Mn
การประกอบของ
การดำเนินการทั้งหมดเข้าด้วยกันก็คือผลคูณ
ที่คุณเห็นตรงนี้
และคุณเห็นว่าลำดับ
กลับกันอีกครั้งด้วยเหตุผลเดียวกันกับก่อนหน้า
สรุปสั้นๆ การประกอบ
ของการดำเนินการแบบความน่าจะเป็นถูกแทนด้วยผลคูณ
ของเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกที่แทนมัน
โดยจำไว้ว่านี่เป็น
ลำดับของเมทริกซ์ในผลคูณ
คุณจะได้เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกเสมอจากการคูณ
เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกแบบนี้ และบางครั้งเราแสดงข้อเท็จจริงนี้
โดยบอกว่าเมทริกซ์
สโตแคสติกปิดภายใต้การคูณ และวิธีที่คุณ
คิดเรื่องนี้ก็คือคุณไม่สามารถออกจากเซต
ของเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก
ด้วยการคูณมันเพราะเซตนั้นปิด
กลับมาที่เรื่อง
ลำดับของเมทริกซ์ในผลคูณ สิ่งสำคัญคือต้องสังเกตว่า
ลำดับมันสำคัญจริงๆ
การคูณเมทริกซ์ไม่สลับที่ ถ้าคุณเปลี่ยนลำดับของ
เมทริกซ์ในผลคูณ คุณอาจเปลี่ยนผลลัพธ์
และเราไม่ต้องมองไกลไปกว่าการดำเนินการ
แบบกำหนดได้เพื่อเห็นสิ่งนี้
นี่คือตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ของ
เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติกสองตัว ทั้งคู่แทน
การดำเนินการแบบกำหนดได้ที่ลำดับมีความสำคัญ
M1 แทนฟังก์ชันคงที่ศูนย์ สมมติว่าเรากำลังจินตนาการว่าการดำเนินการทั้งสองนี้ทำกับบิต เหมือนในตัวอย่างก่อนหน้า
M2 แทนการดำเนินการ NOT
หรือบิตฟลิป
ถ้าคุณทำ M1 ก่อน
แล้วทำ M2 ผลลัพธ์คือเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ ซึ่งแทน
ฟังก์ชันคงที่หนึ่ง
ถ้าคุณตั้งบิตเป็นศูนย์
แล้วพลิกมัน ก็เหมือนกับแค่
ตั้งบิตนั้นเป็นหนึ่ง
อีกด้านหนึ่ง ถ้าคุณทำ M2 ก่อน
แล้วทำ M1 ผลลัพธ์ก็คือตรงนี้
และมันสมเหตุสมผลเพราะถ้าคุณพลิกบิต
แล้วตั้งมันเป็นศูนย์ มันก็เหมือนกับ
แค่ตั้งมันเป็นศูนย์
ไม่สำคัญว่าคุณพลิกมัน เห็นได้ชัดว่าเมทริกซ์สองตัวนี้
ไม่เหมือนกัน เราจึงมีตัวอย่าง
ง่ายๆ ที่เผยว่า
ลำดับมันสำคัญ แน่นอนว่านี่ไม่น่าแปลกใจเลย
เราทุกคนรู้ว่าลำดับที่
การดำเนินการถูกทำนั้นสำคัญ หรืออย่างน้อยก็อาจสำคัญ
ตัวอย่างเช่น ถ้าคุณจุด
ไม้ขีดไฟแล้วเป่า ผลลัพธ์จะต่างมาก
จากการเป่าไม้ขีดไฟก่อน
แล้วค่อยจุด ตอนนี้เราพูดเรื่อง
สารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกมาเยอะแล้ว และถึงเวลาที่จะ
พูดถึงสารสนเทศควอนตัม
และสิ่งที่เราจะพบก็คือ
ในทางคณิตศาสตร์ สารสนเทศควอนตัม
ทำงานในแบบที่คล้ายกับสารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิกมาก
โดยมีความแตกต่างสำคัญบางอย่าง
ความแตกต่างสำคัญแรก
อยู่ตรงจุดเริ่มต้น วิธีที่เรานิยามสถานะ ในกรณีนี้คือสถานะควอนตัมของระบบ
และมีความหมายหนึ่งที่ตัวเลือกเดียวนี้ วิธีที่
เรานิยามสถานะควอนตัม เป็นตัวกำหนดเป็นส่วนใหญ่ว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไง
เราจะนิยามด้วยว่า
การวัดและการดำเนินการทำงานยังไง และในบทเรียนถัดไป เราจะพูดถึงว่า
สารสนเทศควอนตัมทำงานยังไงไม่ใช่แค่สำหรับระบบเดี่ยว
แต่สำหรับหลายระบบ
แต่สิ่งเหล่านี้จริงๆ
ตามมาค่อนข้างเป็นธรรมชาติเมื่อแนวคิดของสถานะควอนตัมของระบบเดี่ยวที่
แยกอยู่ตามลำพังถูกสร้างขึ้นแล้ว
นี่คือนิยาม สถานะควอนตัมของระบบถูกแทนด้วยเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ที่มีดัชนีที่จับคู่
กับสถานะคลาสสิก
ของระบบนั้น
เราสมมติตรงนี้ว่า
ระบบที่เราพูดถึงมีเซตของสถานะคลาสสิก เหมือนกับเวลาพูดถึง
สารสนเทศแบบคลาสสิก
และสถานะความน่าจะเป็น รายการในเวกเตอร์
สถานะควอนตัมเป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน ต่างจากกรณีความน่าจะเป็น
ที่รายการเป็น
จำนวนจริงที่ไม่เป็นลบ
และคราวนี้ ผลรวมของค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองของรายการต้องเท่ากับหนึ่ง ต่างจากผลรวมที่เท่ากับหนึ่ง
อย่างที่เรามีในกรณีความน่าจะเป็น
จำนวนเชิงซ้อนที่ปรากฏ
ในเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมบางครั้งเรียกว่าแอมพลิจูด และมีบทบาท
คล้ายกับความน่าจะเป็น
แต่มันไม่ใช่ความน่าจะเป็นและไม่มี
การตีความเดียวกัน
ผมให้เหตุผลดีๆ ไม่ได้ว่าทำไมสถานะควอนตัม
ควรถูกนิยามแบบนี้ นอกจากจะบอกว่า
นักฟิสิกส์ค้นพบ
ว่านิยามนี้
เกี่ยวข้องกับกายภาพจริงและทำให้เราอธิบายและจำลอง
ระบบกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมได้
พูดอีกอย่างก็คือ เราเลือกนิยามนี้
เพราะมันใช้ได้ ไม่ใช่เพราะมี
เหตุผลเฉพาะใดๆ ว่าทำไมสถานะควอนตัมควร
ถูกนิยามแบบนี้
ในแง่ของ
คณิตศาสตร์ของแนวคิดสถานะควอนตัมนี้ ขั้นแรกสู่การเข้าใจและทำงานกับมันคือ
จำนิยามนี้ไว้
สำหรับนอร์มแบบยุคลิดของเวกเตอร์ ซึ่งคุณคิดในเชิงเรขาคณิตได้ว่าเป็นความยาวของเวกเตอร์ เหมือนกับที่คุณคิดเกี่ยวกับความยาว
ของเวกเตอร์จริงสองมิติ ถ้าคุณวาดมันบนกระดาษ
เป็นลูกศรเริ่มจากจุดกำเนิดตามวิธีปกติ
โดยเฉพาะ ถ้าเรามี
เวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ v แบบนี้ ซึ่งเราสมมติว่ามี
ค่าจำนวนเชิงซ้อน alpha one ถึง alpha n
นอร์มแบบยุคลิดของ v จะถูกนิยามตามที่เห็นตรงนี้เลย
นี่คือสัญกรณ์ที่เรา
ใช้สำหรับนอร์มแบบยุคลิด โดยใส่แถบคู่รอบเวกเตอร์ที่เรากำลังพูดถึง
ในกรณีนี้คือ v และนอร์มแบบยุคลิดถูกนิยามว่าเป็นรากที่สองของผลรวม
ของค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสอง
ของค่าในเวกเตอร์
อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการนิยามว่า
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมคืออะไร ก็คือเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ที่มี
ค่าจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
ที่มีนอร์มแบบยุคลิดเท่ากับหนึ่ง ซึ่งก็คือมันเป็นเวกเตอร์หนึ่งหน่วยเทียบกับนอร์มแบบยุคลิด
นั่นเป็นเพราะผลรวมของ
ค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองเท่ากับหนึ่ง ก็ต่อเมื่อนอร์มแบบยุคลิด
เท่ากับหนึ่ง
รากที่สองไม่เปลี่ยนอะไรเลยเมื่อผลรวมของค่า
สัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองเท่ากับหนึ่ง
นั่นคือสิ่งที่เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเป็น มันคือเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ที่มีดัชนีตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบ
ที่มีค่าจำนวนเชิงซ้อนและนอร์มแบบยุคลิดเท่ากับหนึ่ง
สิ่งที่มันหมายความหรือสิ่งที่มันบ่งบอกหรือเราควรตีความ
แนวคิดนี้ยังไง เป็นเรื่องที่ต่างออกไป และในแง่หนึ่ง
การศึกษาข้อมูล
ควอนตัมและการคำนวณเป็นการสำรวจว่า
นิยามนี้บ่งบอกอะไร อย่างน้อยในแง่ของ
การประมวลผลข้อมูล
นี่เป็นแค่จุดเริ่มต้นเท่านั้น
นอกเรื่องนิดนึง ขอพูดถึงว่ามี
นอร์มแบบอื่นนอกเหนือจากนอร์มแบบยุคลิด และสัญกรณ์ตรงนี้
ที่มีแถบคู่
รอบเวกเตอร์ไม่ได้หมายถึง
นอร์มแบบยุคลิดเสมอไป
ในบริบทอื่น สัญกรณ์นี้อาจหมายถึง
นอร์มแบบอื่นก็ได้
ตัวอย่างเช่น ผลรวม
ของค่าสัมบูรณ์โดยไม่มียกกำลังสองหรือราก
ที่สอง ก็เป็นนอร์มแบบอื่น
ซึ่งมักเรียกว่านอร์มหนึ่ง จริงๆ แล้วมี
นอร์มแบบต่างๆ เยอะมาก
บางทีจะเห็น
สัญกรณ์นี้ถูกใช้พร้อมตัวห้อยหลัง
แถบชุดที่สอง ซึ่งให้ข้อมูลเพิ่มเติมว่าเรากำลังพูดถึงนอร์มแบบไหน
และเมื่อเราทำแบบนั้น ก็ค่อนข้างปกติที่เลขสองเป็นตัวห้อย
จะหมายถึงนอร์มแบบยุคลิด
แต่ในซีรีส์นี้ เมื่อไหร่ก็ตามที่เรามี
เวกเตอร์คอลัมน์แบบนี้ สัญกรณ์แถบคู่เพียงอย่างเดียว
หมายถึงนอร์มแบบยุคลิด
นี่คือตัวอย่างบางส่วน
ของเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม และเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเหล่านี้คือเวกเตอร์สถานะ qubit
ซึ่งหมายความว่า
สถานะคลาสสิกของระบบเราคือศูนย์และหนึ่ง
คำว่า qubit ย่อมาจาก quantum bit ซึ่งจริงๆ แล้วก็แค่บิต
ที่สามารถอยู่ในสถานะควอนตัมได้
สองตัวอย่างแรกง่ายมาก เวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน
เคท์ศูนย์และเคท์หนึ่ง เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ทั้งคู่เป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ และดัชนีตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกคือศูนย์และหนึ่ง และค่าของ
เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
สำหรับเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้โดยเฉพาะ ค่าคือศูนย์และหนึ่ง ซึ่งเป็นจำนวนจริง และจริงๆ แล้วเป็นจำนวนเต็ม แต่ก็เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนด้วย
ที่บังเอิญมี
ส่วนจินตภาพเท่ากับศูนย์
แต่ละเวกเตอร์มีค่าหนึ่งตัวเท่ากับหนึ่งและค่าหนึ่งตัวเท่ากับศูนย์
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราบวกค่า
สัมบูรณ์ของค่าต่างๆ เข้าด้วยกัน เราจะได้หนึ่งในทั้งสองกรณี
เงื่อนไข
ที่จำเป็นสำหรับเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้จะเป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมก็เป็นอันสำเร็จ
สองตัวอย่างถัดไปเป็นสถานะ qubit ที่พบเจอบ่อยมาก เรียกว่าสถานะบวกและสถานะลบ
เขียนแทนได้ตามที่
เห็นบนหน้าจอ ไม่ว่าจะเป็นเคท์บวก
หรือเคท์ลบแบบนี้ และถูกนิยามตาม
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
อีกครั้ง ค่าของ
เวกเตอร์เหล่านี้เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน คราวนี้เป็นบวกหนึ่งหารรากที่สองของสอง หรือลบหนึ่งหารรากที่สองของสอง
และเมื่อเราบวก
ค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสอง เราจะได้ 1/2 บวก 1/2 ซึ่งเท่ากับหนึ่ง
เกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้ การใส่
เครื่องหมายบวกหรือลบเข้าไปในเคท์แบบนี้
อาจดูแปลกๆ เพราะมันไม่ใช่สถานะ
คลาสสิกของระบบเรา
แต่สัญกรณ์นี้ก็ถูกใช้อยู่ดี และเราจะกลับมาพูดถึงเรื่องนี้อีกสักครู่
แต่สำหรับตอนนี้ สรุปสั้นๆ เราสามารถใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac ใส่ชื่ออะไรก็ได้ที่ต้องการสำหรับเวกเตอร์เข้าไปในเคท์
เวกเตอร์ไม่จำเป็นต้อง
เป็นเวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐานเมื่อเราใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac
นี่คือตัวอย่างสถานะ qubit
สุดท้ายสำหรับตอนนี้
มันเป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมของ qubit ที่ไม่มีชื่อพิเศษ และไม่ได้สำคัญอะไรเป็นพิเศษ
ค่าของเวกเตอร์นี้คือหนึ่งบวกสองคูณ i
หารสาม และลบ 2/3
เหล่านี้เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อน และถ้าคำนวณ
ค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของสองค่านี้ จะได้ 5/9 สำหรับตัวแรก
และ 4/9 สำหรับตัวที่สอง ดังนั้นผลรวมของค่า
สัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองเท่ากับหนึ่ง
และนี่คือตัวอย่างสุดท้าย คราวนี้สำหรับระบบ
ที่สถานะคลาสสิกคือสี่ชุดไพ่
ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่าทำไมเราถึงจะมีระบบที่สถานะคลาสสิก
เป็นสี่ชุดไพ่แล้วอยู่ในสถานะควอนตัม แต่มันเป็นไปได้ในหลักการ
และมันแค่เป็นตัวอย่างเท่านั้นเอง
ค่าที่ตรงกับ
ชุดไพ่ต่างๆ คือ 1/2 สำหรับดอกจิก ลบ
i หารสอง สำหรับข้าวหลามตัด
ศูนย์สำหรับโพแดงเพราะมันไม่ปรากฏในผลรวม และหนึ่งหาร
รากที่สองของสอง สำหรับโพดำ
และนี่คือหน้าตาของมัน
เมื่อเขียนเป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ โดยสมมติว่าเราเรียงลำดับ
สถานะคลาสสิกตามที่ทำก่อนหน้านี้
ซึ่งเป็นลำดับที่
เห็นตรงนี้
เมื่อหาค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองของค่าเหล่านี้ ได้หนึ่งส่วนสี่สำหรับตัวแรก และหนึ่งส่วนสี่เหมือนกันสำหรับตัวถัดไป
ค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสอง
ของศูนย์เท่ากับศูนย์ ดังนั้นค่านั้นไม่ได้
มีส่วนในผลรวม
และสุดท้ายสำหรับตัวสุดท้าย เราได้ 1/2 ดังนั้นผลรวมเท่ากับหนึ่ง ตามที่ต้องการเพื่อให้เวกเตอร์นี้
เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
เมื่อกี้ เราใช้สัญกรณ์
เคท์บวกและเคท์ลบเพื่ออ้างถึงเวกเตอร์สถานะ qubit สองตัวที่ไม่ใช่เวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน
และอยากจะกลับมา
พูดถึงจุดนี้สักครู่ และอธิบายว่าสัญกรณ์ Dirac ถูกใช้ยังไงสำหรับเวกเตอร์ทั่วไป ไม่ใช่แค่เวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน
อย่างที่พูดไปแล้ว เราสามารถใช้ชื่ออะไรก็ได้ที่
ต้องการข้างในบราหรือเคท์เพื่ออ้างถึงเวกเตอร์
เคท์คือเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
และบราคือเวกเตอร์แถว เหมือนเดิม
เป็นตัวอย่าง ตัวอักษรกรีก
พซายถูกใช้บ่อยมากข้างในเคท์เพื่ออ้างถึงเวกเตอร์ทั่วไปบางตัว
และตรงนี้เราใช้มัน
เพื่อตั้งชื่อให้เวกเตอร์สถานะจากก่อนหน้าที่ไม่
มีชื่อพิเศษ
เมื่อเราทำแบบนี้ ตัวอักษรพซายไม่จำเป็น
ต้องมีความหมายอะไรในตัวมันเอง
มันแค่เป็นชื่อของเวกเตอร์ และอยู่ข้างในเคท์เพื่อช่วยให้ชัดเจน
ว่ามันเป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
อันนี้อาจ
สับสนได้บ้าง และมีโอกาสคลุมเครือได้ถ้าตัวอักษรพซายอาจเชื่อมโยงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกของ
ระบบใดระบบหนึ่งเป็นต้น แต่โดยทั่วไปแล้วไม่ได้
ทำให้เกิดปัญหาอะไร และไม่จำเป็นต้องใช้
สัญกรณ์ Dirac แบบนี้
ถ้าไม่อยากใช้ก็ได้ การใช้ตัวอักษรพิมพ์เล็กเช่น
u, v หรือ w โดยไม่มีเคท์ก็เป็นวิธีที่ดี
ในการเขียนแทนเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
หรือพูดให้เจาะจงกว่านั้น
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
เลือกใช้สัญกรณ์อะไร
ก็ได้ตามที่ชอบ
แค่ต้องแน่ใจว่า
ข้อหนึ่ง ความหมายของสิ่งที่
พยายามจะสื่อนั้นชัดเจนสำหรับคนอื่น
และข้อสอง เข้าใจสิ่งที่
คนอื่นพยายามจะสื่อ แม้ว่าสัญกรณ์ที่เขาชอบใช้จะไม่เหมือนกับของเรา
มีกฎสำคัญข้อหนึ่งสำหรับการใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac
กับเวกเตอร์ทั่วไป ก็คือถ้ามี
เวกเตอร์คอลัมน์
ที่ตัดสินใจจะเขียนเป็น
เคท์พซาย เป็นต้น หรืออาจจะเป็นชื่ออื่น
ข้างในเคท์ก็ได้ แล้วเวกเตอร์แถว บราพซาย
จะถูกเข้าใจว่าเป็น
สังยุคทรานสโพสของเวกเตอร์เคท์พซาย
และตรงนี้เขียนเป็นสมการที่มีเครื่องหมายดากเกอร์ตรงนี้หมายถึงสังยุคทรานสโพส
สิ่งที่มันเป็นโดยเฉพาะก็คือ
เวกเตอร์แถวที่ได้จาก ข้อหนึ่ง ทรานสโพสเวกเตอร์ คือพลิก
เวกเตอร์ไปด้านข้างแล้วเปลี่ยนจากคอลัมน์เป็นแถว
โดยไม่ได้เปลี่ยนค่าจริงๆ และข้อสอง หาสังยุคเชิงซ้อน
ของแต่ละค่า
จริงๆ แล้วสามารถทำ
สองการดำเนินการนี้ คือทรานสโพสและ
สังยุคเชิงซ้อนของแต่ละค่า ในลำดับไหนก่อนก็ได้ เพราะสอง
การดำเนินการนี้สลับกันได้
ดังนั้นสำหรับเวกเตอร์ในตัวอย่างนี้ เมื่อเราตัดสินใจ
เรียกเวกเตอร์นี้ว่าเคท์พซาย เป็นที่เข้าใจว่าบราพซาย
หมายถึงเวกเตอร์ตรงนี้
ที่เราทรานสโพสเวกเตอร์โดยเปลี่ยนเคท์ศูนย์และ
เคท์หนึ่งเป็นบราศูนย์และบราหนึ่ง และเราหาสังยุค
เชิงซ้อนของแต่ละค่า
ซึ่งเป็นเหตุผลว่าทำไม
หนึ่งบวกสองคูณ i หารสาม ถึงกลายเป็นหนึ่งลบสอง
คูณ i หารสาม ตรงนี้
นี่คือหน้าตาของเวกเตอร์เหล่านี้เมื่อเขียน
เป็นเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์และเวกเตอร์แถวอย่างชัดเจน
สังเกตนะว่า
กฎนี้สอดคล้องกับสัญกรณ์ที่เราใช้เมื่อมีสถานะคลาสสิก
อยู่ข้างในบราและเคท์
ในกรณีนั้น ค่าทั้งหมดเป็น
ศูนย์ยกเว้นตัวหนึ่งที่เป็นหนึ่ง ดังนั้นการหาสังยุค
เชิงซ้อนไม่ได้เปลี่ยนอะไรในกรณีนั้น
เราได้เห็นแล้วว่าสถานะควอนตัมถูกแทนด้วยเวกเตอร์ยังไง แต่ยังไม่ชัดเจน ณ จุดนี้
ว่าความหมายหรือผลกระทบคืออะไร
ในแง่ของสิ่งที่
ทำได้กับระบบในสถานะควอนตัม หรือจะมีปฏิสัมพันธ์กับมันยังไง
สิ่งแรกที่ต้องทำเพื่อให้ประเด็นเหล่านี้ชัดขึ้น
คือพูดเรื่องการวัด
พูดอย่างเข้าใจง่าย
การวัดเป็นกลไกสำหรับดึงข้อมูล
คลาสสิกออกจากระบบควอนตัม
เมื่อเราดูระบบ
ตอนที่มันอยู่ในสถานะควอนตัม เราไม่เห็นสถานะควอนตัม เหมือนกับที่เราไม่เห็น
สถานะเชิงความน่าจะเป็น
เราเห็นสถานะคลาสสิก และแนวคิดเรื่องการวัดนี้เป็นสิ่งที่ให้อินเทอร์เฟซนั้น
ถ้าเราในฐานะมนุษย์อยากรู้อะไรบางอย่างเกี่ยวกับระบบควอนตัม เราต้องวัดมัน และเมื่อทำเช่นนั้น เราจะดึงข้อมูลคลาสสิก
เกี่ยวกับสถานะควอนตัม
ที่ระบบนั้นอยู่ออกมาได้
มีแนวคิดเรื่อง
การวัดแบบต่างๆ ความแตกต่างเป็นเรื่อง
ของระดับความทั่วไปจริงๆ และเราจะเริ่มด้วยแบบที่ง่ายที่สุดและพื้นฐานที่สุด
ซึ่งโดยปกติเรียกว่า
การวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน
เราจะขยายความเรื่องนี้
ในบทเรียนถัดไป เราจะพูดถึงสิ่งที่เรียกว่า
การวัดแบบโปรเจกทีฟในบทเรียนที่สาม และต่อไปใน
หน่วยที่สามของซีรีส์
เราจะพูดถึงการวัดทั่วไป ซึ่งเรียกอีกอย่างว่า positive
operator valued measures หรือ POVMs แบบย่อ
แต่สำหรับตอนนี้ เราจะจำกัดความสนใจไว้ที่การวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน
เมื่อทำการวัด
กับระบบ จะมีเซตของ
ผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้ของการวัดนั้น ซึ่งเป็นผลลัพธ์คลาสสิก
และในกรณีของ
การวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน ผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้เหล่านั้น
ก็คือสถานะคลาสสิกของระบบที่ถูกวัดนั่นเอง
แต่ละสถานะคลาสสิกจะเป็นผลลัพธ์ของการวัดด้วยความน่าจะเป็นบางค่า และความน่าจะเป็นนั้นคือ
ค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสอง
ของค่าที่ตรงกับ
สถานะคลาสสิกนั้นในเวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัมที่ระบบอยู่ก่อนที่จะถูกวัดทันที
เรารู้ว่าค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของจำนวนเชิงซ้อนใดๆ เป็นจำนวนจริงที่ไม่ติดลบ และเรารู้จากนิยาม
ของเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ว่าผลรวมของค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองของค่าในเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเท่ากับหนึ่ง
ดังนั้นมันก็สมเหตุสมผล แต่ละสถานะคลาสสิกจะปรากฏเป็นผลลัพธ์ของ
การวัดด้วยความน่าจะเป็นบางค่า และความน่าจะเป็นรวมกันได้หนึ่ง
นี่คือตัวอย่างบางส่วน อย่างแรก สมมติว่าเรามี
qubit ในสถานะบวก
ถ้าเราวัด qubit นี้ด้วยการวัด
แบบฐานมาตรฐาน เราจะได้ศูนย์หรือ
หนึ่งเป็นผลลัพธ์
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ศูนย์คือค่าสัมบูรณ์
ยกกำลังสองของหนึ่งหารรากที่สองของสอง ซึ่งคือ 1/2 และนั่นก็เป็นความน่าจะเป็น
เดียวกันกับที่จะได้หนึ่ง
ดังนั้นถ้าวัดสถานะบวก จะได้บิตสุ่มแบบสม่ำเสมอ
ถ้าระบบอยู่ในสถานะ
ลบแทนที่จะเป็นสถานะบวก การวัดก็ทำงาน
เหมือนกันเป๊ะ
ความน่าจะเป็นก็เป็น 1/2 อีกครั้งสำหรับแต่ละผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้
ความแตกต่างเดียวตรงนี้คือเครื่องหมายบวกกลายเป็นลบ แต่เมื่อหาค่า
สัมบูรณ์ ไม่มีอะไรเปลี่ยน
ถ้าเราวัดสถานะ qubit นี้ ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์คือค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของหนึ่งบวกสองคูณ i
หารสาม ซึ่งคือ 5/9
และความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้ผลลัพธ์หนึ่งคือค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสอง
ของลบ 2/3 ซึ่งคือ 4/9
และสุดท้าย การวัด
สถานะฐานมาตรฐาน เคท์ศูนย์จะได้ผลลัพธ์
ศูนย์อย่างแน่นอน และเช่นเดียวกัน การวัดสถานะเคท์หนึ่ง
จะได้ผลลัพธ์หนึ่งอย่างแน่นอน นั่นเพราะค่า
สัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของหนึ่งคือหนึ่ง
คล้ายกับสิ่งที่มีใน
กรณีเชิงความน่าจะเป็น เราสามารถเชื่อมโยงสถานะ
ควอนตัมเหล่านี้ เคท์ศูนย์และเคท์หนึ่ง กับการที่ระบบอยู่ใน
สถานะคลาสสิกเหล่านั้น
และตัวอย่างนี้สอดคล้อง
กับการตีความนั้น
ทีนี้ เหมือนกับที่มีใน
กรณีเชิงความน่าจะเป็น ถ้าเราวัดระบบตอนที่
มันอยู่ในสถานะควอนตัม
สถานะก็จะเปลี่ยน โดยทั่วไป อันเป็นผลจากการ
ทำการวัดนั้น
โดยเฉพาะ และอีกครั้ง นี่เหมือนกับสิ่งที่มี
ในกรณีเชิงความน่าจะเป็นเป๊ะ
ถ้าเราวัดระบบและผลลัพธ์ของการวัด
คือสถานะคลาสสิก a แล้วสถานะควอนตัมใหม่
ของระบบจะกลายเป็นเคท์ a
ดังนั้นสำหรับสถานะตรง
นี้เป็นต้น เราเห็นพฤติกรรมแบบเดียวกัน
กับที่มีในกรณีเชิงความน่าจะเป็น
ถ้าเราวัด ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น 5/9 เราได้ผลลัพธ์ศูนย์ ซึ่งในกรณีนั้นสถานะ
เปลี่ยนไปเป็นเคท์ศูนย์
และด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
4/9 ผลลัพธ์คือหนึ่ง และสถานะเปลี่ยนไปเป็นเคท์หนึ่ง
บางทีปรากฏการณ์นี้ถูกเรียกว่าการยุบตัว
ของสถานะควอนตัม และมันเป็นเรื่องที่ทำให้
คนที่
ศึกษารากฐาน
ของกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมนอนไม่หลับ
แต่จากมุมมอง
ทางคณิตศาสตร์ล้วนๆ มันค่อนข้างง่าย
และคล้ายคลึงมากกับสิ่งที่มีในกรณีเชิงความน่าจะเป็น
จุดที่ขัดแย้งตรงนี้ ในแง่หนึ่ง เกี่ยวข้องกับธรรมชาติพื้นฐาน
ของสถานะควอนตัมและสิ่งที่มันแทน
และมันต่างยังไง
จากสถานะเชิงความน่าจะเป็น แต่ในระดับคณิตศาสตร์ นี่อาจเป็นสิ่งที่คาดหวังได้
สังเกตนะว่าถ้า
วัดครั้งที่สอง ก็จะได้
ผลลัพธ์เดียวกันเป๊ะกับการวัดครั้งแรก
ดังนั้นมีข้อจำกัดว่า
ข้อมูลคลาสสิกจะถูกดึงออกจากสถานะควอนตัมได้มากแค่ไหน และเราจะกลับมาพูดเรื่องนี้เร็วๆ นี้
ในบทเรียนอื่น เราพูดถึงสถานะควอนตัมรวมถึงการวัดแล้ว โดยเฉพาะการวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน
ซึ่งเป็นวิธี
ดึงข้อมูลคลาสสิกออกจากสถานะควอนตัม
หัวข้อที่เหลือ
สำหรับบทเรียนนี้คือการดำเนินการ โดยเฉพาะการดำเนินการแบบยูนิทารี ซึ่งอธิบายว่า
สถานะควอนตัมของระบบ
เปลี่ยนแปลงได้ยังไง โดยธรรมชาติแล้ว เมื่อ
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมต่างจากเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น ก็คาดหวังได้ว่าเซตของการดำเนินการ
ที่อนุญาต
บนสถานะควอนตัมจะต่างจากสิ่งที่มีสำหรับ
ข้อมูลคลาสสิก และนั่นก็เป็นเช่นนั้นจริงๆ
ในขณะที่การดำเนินการบนสถานะเชิงความน่าจะเป็นถูกแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก การดำเนินการบนเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ถูกแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
นี่คือนิยามของเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัส U ที่มีค่า
จำนวนเชิงซ้อน เป็นยูนิทารีถ้ามันเป็นไปตามสมการ
ที่เห็นตรงนี้
เครื่องหมายดากเกอร์แทน
สังยุคทรานสโพส ซึ่งเราเห็นไปแล้วสำหรับเวกเตอร์ตอนที่พูดถึงสัญกรณ์
Dirac เมื่อกี้
ตรงนี้เรากำลังทำ
สังยุคทรานสโพสกับเมทริกซ์แทนที่จะเป็นเวกเตอร์ แต่มันเหมือนกันโดยพื้นฐาน
เราทรานสโพสเมทริกซ์ ซึ่งก็แค่
สลับแถวกับคอลัมน์ ค่าตำแหน่ง JK กลายเป็นค่าตำแหน่ง KJ
และก็หาสังยุคเชิงซ้อน
ของแต่ละค่าด้วย
นอกจากนี้ สัญกรณ์ตรงนี้
หมายถึงเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์
สมการสองข้อตรง
นี้จริงๆ แล้วเท่ากัน ถ้ามีข้อหนึ่ง ก็
ได้อีกข้อโดยอัตโนมัติ
ทั้งสองข้อเทียบเท่ากับ
การบอกว่า U หาอินเวอร์สได้ และอินเวอร์สเท่ากับ
สังยุคทรานสโพส
นั่นเป็นจริงสำหรับ
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัสเท่านั้นนะ ถ้ามีเมทริกซ์ที่ไม่ใช่จัตุรัส สมการข้อใดข้อหนึ่ง
อาจเป็นจริง
แต่อีกข้อจะไม่เป็นจริง
แต่ตรงนี้เรากำลังพูดถึง
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัส
นี่คือนิยามมาตรฐาน
สำหรับเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี และมันดีเพราะง่ายต่อการตรวจสอบ
ว่าเมทริกซ์เป็นยูนิทารีหรือเปล่า
แค่คูณเมทริกซ์กับสังยุคทรานสโพสของมันทั้งสองด้าน แล้วดูว่าได้
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หรือเปล่า
มีอีกวิธีหนึ่งที่เทียบเท่ากันในการบ่งบอกเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี ก็คือ
เมทริกซ์จัตุรัสเป็นยูนิทารีก็ต่อเมื่อมันไม่เคย
เปลี่ยนนอร์มแบบยุคลิด
ของเวกเตอร์ใดๆ เมื่อคูณเข้าไป เมทริกซ์ N คูณ N U จะเป็นยูนิทารีก็ต่อเมื่อ
นอร์มแบบยุคลิดของ U คูณ v
เท่ากับนอร์มแบบยุคลิดของ v สำหรับเวกเตอร์คอลัมน์ N มิติ v ทุกตัวที่มีค่าจำนวนเชิงซ้อน
ดังนั้นถ้า v เป็น
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม U คูณ v ก็เป็น
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมด้วย เพราะเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ก็แค่เป็นเวกเตอร์ที่มี
นอร์มแบบยุคลิดเท่ากับหนึ่ง
จริงๆ แล้วเราพูดได้มากกว่านั้นอีก ก็คือเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีเป็นเมทริกซ์กลุ่มเดียวกันเป๊ะที่แปลง
เวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม
ให้เป็นเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมเสมอ นั่นเป็นสถานการณ์คล้ายๆ กับที่มีสำหรับเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก
และเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็น
เมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก
เป็นเมทริกซ์กลุ่มเดียวกันเป๊ะที่แปลงเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นให้เป็นเวกเตอร์ความน่าจะเป็นเสมอ
ดังนั้นเมื่อเราตัดสินใจแล้วว่าการดำเนินการควรถูกแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ ซึ่งก็เหมือนกับการบอกว่าการแปลงทำงานเชิงเส้น
บนเวกเตอร์ที่แทนสถานะ ทางเลือกเหล่านี้สำหรับเซตของ
การดำเนินการที่อนุญาตก็ตามมาอย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ อย่างน้อย
ในแง่คณิตศาสตร์
ทีนี้มาดูตัวอย่างของการดำเนินการยูนิทารีของ qubit กัน
เราจะเห็นตัวอย่างอีกมากมาย
ของการดำเนินการยูนิทารีในบทเรียนถัดไป รวมถึงการดำเนินการยูนิทารีบนระบบ
ที่มีสถานะคลาสสิกมากกว่าสอง แต่สำหรับตอนนี้เราจะโฟกัสแค่
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีของ qubit
เราจะเห็นตัวอย่าง
เฉพาะเหล่านี้ปรากฏขึ้นซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่า ดังนั้นมันคุ้มค่ามากที่จะทำความรู้จัก
กับการดำเนินการเหล่านี้
กลุ่มตัวอย่างแรกคือการดำเนินการเพาลีที่เรียกกันว่า
เหล่านี้คือการดำเนินการที่ตรงกับเมทริกซ์เพาลี ซึ่งแสดงอยู่ตรงนี้
ทุกตัวเป็นยูนิทารี และสามารถตรวจสอบได้สำหรับแต่ละตัวตามนิยามจากก่อนหน้า
เมทริกซ์เหล่านี้
บังเอิญเท่ากับสังยุคทรานสโพสของตัวเอง ซึ่งก็คือมัน
เป็นเมทริกซ์เฮอร์มิเชียนทั้งหมด
ดังนั้นการตรวจสอบว่า
ทุกตัวเป็นยูนิทารี ในกรณีนี้ แค่ยกกำลังสองแต่ละตัวแล้วดูว่าผลลัพธ์
เป็นเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หรือเปล่า
ชื่อที่เห็นสำหรับ
เมทริกซ์เหล่านี้ค่อนข้างเป็นมาตรฐาน และจะเห็น
sigma x, sigma y และ sigma z ถูกเรียกสั้นๆ ว่า X, Y และ Z ด้วย
แต่ระวังด้วยนะว่า
ตัวอักษรพิมพ์ใหญ่ X, Y และ Z ก็ถูกใช้บ่อยเพื่อจุดประสงค์อื่นด้วย แม้แต่ในบริบทของ
ข้อมูลควอนตัม
แต่มันเป็นชื่อที่ใช้กัน
ทั่วไปมากสำหรับเมทริกซ์เหล่านี้
การดำเนินการ sigma x หรือ X
ยังเรียกว่าบิตฟลิปหรือการดำเนินการ not ซึ่งเราเห็นไปแล้ว
ในบริบทคลาสสิก
และการดำเนินการ sigma z หรือ Z
ยังเรียกว่าเฟสฟลิป
และตรงนี้เห็นได้ว่า
การดำเนินการเหล่านี้ทำอะไรกับเวกเตอร์ฐานมาตรฐาน ซึ่งอธิบายได้ว่า
ชื่อเหล่านี้มาจากไหน
แน่นอนว่ามันสมเหตุสมผลที่จะ
เรียก sigma x ว่าบิตฟลิปจากการกระทำตรงนี้
มันแค่สลับบิตจาก
ศูนย์เป็นหนึ่ง หรือหนึ่งเป็นศูนย์
และก็สมเหตุสมผลที่จะ
เรียก sigma z ว่าเฟสฟลิปจากการกระทำตรงนี้
แต่ถ้ายังไม่ชัดเจน
ตอนนี้ก็ไม่เป็นไร
เราจะเจอการดำเนินการ
นี้ซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่า และความสำคัญ
ของการใส่เครื่องหมายลบหน้าเวกเตอร์ฐาน
เคท์หนึ่ง แต่ไม่ใส่หน้าเคท์ศูนย์
และทำไมถึงเรียกว่าเฟสฟลิปจะชัดเจนขึ้นทีหลัง
ตัวอย่างถัดไปคือ
การดำเนินการ Hadamard ซึ่งถูกแทนด้วย
เมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ ที่แทบจะเรียกว่า H เสมอ
การตรวจสอบว่า H เป็นยูนิทารีก็เป็น
การคำนวณที่ตรงไปตรงมาอีกครั้ง ถ้าเราหลบออกไป จะเห็นตรงนี้
คล้ายกับเมทริกซ์เพาลี H เป็นสังยุคทรานสโพสของตัวเอง
ดังนั้นเรามีสมการตรงนี้ และเมื่อทำการคูณ เราได้เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ตามที่ต้องการ
ตัวอย่างที่สามเป็น
การดำเนินการทั้งกลุ่มเลย ที่เรียกว่าการดำเนินการเฟส
เหล่านี้คือการดำเนินการ
ที่ถูกแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ที่มีรูปแบบ
ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้ โดย theta เป็นจำนวนจริงใดๆ
ดังนั้นค่าตรงนี้จะ
เป็นจำนวนเชิงซ้อนบนวงกลมหนึ่งหน่วยเสมอ
เมทริกซ์แบบนี้เป็นยูนิทารีเสมอ ซึ่งจะให้ลองตรวจสอบเอง
คราวนี้สังยุคทรานสโพสจะไม่เท่ากับเมทริกซ์ตั้งต้น เว้นแต่ค่าตรงนี้บังเอิญ
เป็นหนึ่งหรือลบหนึ่ง
ซึ่งในกรณีนั้น เราจะได้
เมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์หรือ sigma z ซึ่งเรา
เจอไปแล้ว
โดยเฉพาะ การทรานสโพส
จะไม่ทำอะไรกับเมทริกซ์นี้ แต่การหาสังยุค
เชิงซ้อนของแต่ละค่าจะเปลี่ยนค่าตรงนี้
เป็น e ยกกำลัง ลบ i theta
สองการดำเนินการตรงนี้เป็นตัวอย่างที่สำคัญเป็นพิเศษ
ของการดำเนินการเฟส
สำหรับตัวแรก เราให้
theta เป็นพายหารสอง และได้เมทริกซ์ตรงนี้
นี่มักเรียกว่า
การดำเนินการ S หรือ S gate เมื่อพูดถึง circuit ซึ่งเราจะไม่พูดถึงในบทเรียนนี้
แต่นั่นเป็นหัวข้อสำคัญ
ที่จะมาถึงเร็วๆ นี้
ตัวที่สองคือการดำเนินการนี้ เป็นการดำเนินการ T หรือ T gate
และสำหรับตัวนี้ theta
เท่ากับพายหารสี่ และเมื่อคำนวณเลขชี้กำลัง จะได้ค่าตรงนี้ ซึ่งคือหนึ่งบวก i หาร
รากที่สองของสอง
นี่คือตัวอย่างสั้นๆ ไม่กี่อันเพื่อดูการดำเนินการพวกนี้
ทำงานจริง
นี่คือการกระทำของ
การดำเนินการ Hadamard บนเคท์ศูนย์และเคท์หนึ่ง
ถ้าเราทำ
การคูณเมทริกซ์กับเวกเตอร์ จะเห็นว่าสิ่งที่ได้คือสถานะบวกและ
สถานะลบตามลำดับ
ถ้าเราทำการดำเนินการ Hadamard บนสถานะบวกและ
สถานะลบ ในทางกลับกัน เราจะได้เคท์ศูนย์และเคท์หนึ่งกลับมา
ดังนั้นถ้าจัดให้เรียบร้อยขึ้นหน่อย เราจะเห็นการกระทำได้ชัดเจนขึ้น
การดำเนินการ Hadamard
แปลงไปมาระหว่างสถานะศูนย์กับสถานะบวก และระหว่างสถานะหนึ่ง
กับสถานะลบ
เกี่ยวกับสมการสองข้อตรงนี้ สังเกตว่ามันให้วิธีง่ายๆ ในการตรวจจับความแตกต่างระหว่างสถานะบวกกับสถานะลบ
อย่างที่เห็นก่อนหน้าในบทเรียน ถ้าเราวัดสถานะ
บวกและสถานะลบด้วย
การวัดแบบฐานมาตรฐาน
เราจะได้บิตสุ่มแบบสม่ำเสมอทั้งสองกรณี ซึ่งไม่ช่วยให้
ตรวจจับความแตกต่างได้
แต่ถ้าเราทำการดำเนินการ
Hadamard ก่อนแล้วค่อยวัด เราจะเห็นศูนย์ถ้า
สถานะตั้งต้นเป็นสถานะบวก
และเห็นหนึ่งถ้าสถานะ
ตั้งต้นเป็นสถานะลบ
ดังนั้นสองสถานะนี้ต่างกันจริงๆ และสามารถแยกแยะได้
อย่างสมบูรณ์ด้วยวิธีที่เพิ่งอธิบายไป
ซึ่งก็คือทำการดำเนินการ
Hadamard ก่อนแล้วค่อยวัด
กลับมาที่ตัวอย่าง
ของสถานะ qubit ที่เห็นก่อนหน้าซึ่งไม่ได้พิเศษอะไร เราสามารถดูว่าการดำเนินการ
Hadamard ทำอะไรกับสถานะนี้
โดยแปลงเป็นรูปแบบ
ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้แล้วทำการคูณ
และนี่คือผลลัพธ์
ซึ่งเราสามารถแปลงกลับเป็นสัญกรณ์ Dirac ถ้าต้องการ
และนั่นก็เป็นวิธีหนึ่ง
ในการคำนวณการกระทำแบบนี้
นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างที่แสดงให้เห็นว่าไม่จำเป็นต้อง
แปลงเป็นรูปแบบเมทริกซ์คูณเวกเตอร์ทุกครั้ง
สามารถทำการคำนวณ
เหล่านี้โดยตรงโดยใช้สัญกรณ์ Dirac ก็ได้
ตัวอย่างนี้เกี่ยวกับการดำเนินการ T และนี่คือมัน
ตรงนี้เพื่อเป็นข้อมูลอ้างอิง
การดำเนินการนี้มีการกระทำตรงนี้บนสถานะฐานมาตรฐาน
และถ้าเราต้องการคำนวณ
การกระทำของการดำเนินการ T บนสถานะบวก เป็นต้น เราสามารถเริ่มจากขยาย
นิยามของสถานะบวก
แล้วใช้เชิงเส้น
เพื่อแสดงผลลัพธ์ตามที่เห็นตรงนี้
ตอนนี้เราแค่แทนค่า
นิพจน์จากด้านบนเหล่านี้เข้าไป ทำให้ง่ายขึ้นนิดหน่อย
สำหรับพจน์ที่สอง แล้วเราก็ได้ผลลัพธ์
ถ้าด้วยเหตุผลใดก็ตามอยากจะทำการดำเนินการ
Hadamard กับผลลัพธ์ เราก็ทำแบบคล้ายๆ กันได้
อันดับแรก แทนนิพจน์ของ T ที่กระทำบนสถานะบวกเข้าไป แล้วใช้เชิงเส้นเหมือนที่ทำก่อนหน้า
และตอนนี้ ถ้าเราแทน
นิพจน์ที่มีอยู่แล้วของการดำเนินการ Hadamard
ที่กระทำบนเคท์ศูนย์และเคท์หนึ่ง
เราจะได้แบบนี้ และตอนนี้เราสามารถขยาย
สถานะบวกและสถานะลบเพื่อให้ได้นิพจน์ตรงนี้
ซึ่งเราทำให้ง่ายขึ้นได้แค่บวกเข้าด้วยกัน และนี่คือผลลัพธ์สุดท้าย
ไม่มีอะไรพิเศษเป็นพิเศษ
เกี่ยวกับตัวอย่างนี้ มันแค่ต้องการ
แสดงให้เห็นวิธีอื่นที่เทียบเท่ากันในการ
คำนวณการกระทำ
ของการดำเนินการเหล่านี้ ใช้วิธีไหน
ก็ได้ที่สะดวกกว่าในสถานการณ์นั้นๆ
จุดสุดท้ายเกี่ยวกับ
การดำเนินการยูนิทารีคือ การประกอบกันของการดำเนินการ
ยูนิทารีถูกแทนด้วยการคูณเมทริกซ์
เหมือนกับในกรณีเชิงความน่าจะเป็น คือสามารถคำนวณการกระทำของลำดับการดำเนินการยูนิทารี
โดยแค่คูณ
เมทริกซ์เข้าด้วยกัน แล้วจะได้
เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีตัวเดียวที่แทนการกระทำรวม
ของลำดับการดำเนินการ
เหมือนกับที่มีสำหรับเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
ปิดภายใต้การคูณ ดังนั้นจะได้เมทริกซ์ยูนิทารีเสมอ
เมื่อประกอบการดำเนินการยูนิทารีเข้าด้วยกัน
ต้องแน่ใจว่า
คูณเมทริกซ์ในลำดับที่ถูกต้อง
แต่วิธีทำก็เหมือนกับที่ทำ
สำหรับการดำเนินการสโตแคสติก โดยเมทริกซ์ของ
การดำเนินการแรกที่ทำ
จะอยู่ทางขวามือเสมอ
ของผลคูณเมทริกซ์ และตัวสุดท้ายจะอยู่
ทางซ้ายมือ
เหมือนเดิม ลำดับจะกลับกัน ในแง่ที่ว่าประกอบจากขวาไปซ้ายแทนที่จะเป็นซ้ายไปขวา
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่น่าสนใจที่ให้การดำเนินการที่เรียกว่ารากที่สองของ not
สมมติว่าเราทำ
การดำเนินการ Hadamard ก่อน ตามด้วยการดำเนินการ S ตามด้วยการดำเนินการ Hadamard อีกครั้ง
การกระทำรวมของ
สามการดำเนินการนี้อธิบายได้ด้วยผลคูณนี้
นี่คือการดำเนินการ Hadamard ตัวแรก นี่คือการดำเนินการ S และนี่คือการดำเนินการ Hadamard ตัวที่สอง
ถ้าเราทำการคูณเมทริกซ์ ซึ่งไม่ได้แสดงออกมาชัดเจนตรงนี้ แต่ทำเองได้
ถ้าต้องการ
ผลลัพธ์คือเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ มันเป็นเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี และเราสามารถตรวจสอบได้โดยตรง
หรือเราจะเชื่อว่าเมทริกซ์ยูนิทารี
ปิดภายใต้การคูณก็ได้
มันต้องเป็นยูนิทารีเพราะเมทริกซ์สามตัวนี้เป็นยูนิทารีอย่างที่เราเห็นไปแล้ว
เราไม่ได้มีเวกเตอร์สถานะ
ควอนตัมตัวใดเจาะจงอยู่ในใจ
เราสามารถจินตนาการว่า
ทำลำดับการดำเนินการนี้กับเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัมตัวไหนก็ได้ และเมทริกซ์นี้อธิบายการกระทำ
เหตุผลที่การดำเนินการรวมนี้ คือตัวที่อธิบาย
ด้วยเมทริกซ์ตรงนี้ ถูกเรียกว่ารากที่สองของ not
ก็เพราะว่าเมื่อทำมัน
สองครั้ง จะได้การดำเนินการ not หรือพูดอีกอย่างก็คือ
sigma x หรือการดำเนินการ X
การทำการดำเนินการ
สองครั้งถูกแทนด้วยการยกกำลังสองเมทริกซ์หรือ
คูณมันกับตัวเอง
และถ้าทำแบบนี้ จะเห็นว่าผลลัพธ์
คือเมทริกซ์เพาลี x
และนั่นค่อนข้างแปลก และมันให้เบาะแสว่าทำอะไรน่าสนใจๆ ได้กับข้อมูลควอนตัมที่ทำไม่ได้กับ
ข้อมูลคลาสสิก
ไม่มีการดำเนินการคลาสสิก คือตัวที่ถูกแทน
ด้วยเมทริกซ์สโตแคสติก ที่ให้การดำเนินการ not
ถ้าทำมันสองครั้ง
ดังนั้นเป็นตัวอย่างที่ดีที่เผยให้เห็นว่าการดำเนินการควอนตัม
ทำงานต่างจากการดำเนินการคลาสสิกมาก
และนั่นก็จบบทเรียนที่หนึ่ง ในบทเรียนนี้เราพูดถึงว่าข้อมูลควอนตัมทำงานยังไงสำหรับระบบเดี่ยวที่แยกจากกัน
และในบทเรียนถัดไป เราจะพูดถึงว่า
ข้อมูลควอนตัมทำงานยังไงสำหรับหลายระบบ
ขอบคุณที่รับชม ถ้ามีคำถามอะไร ถามได้เลยใน
ส่วนคอมเมนต์ด้านล่าง